tom brady acknowledging
in an article nearly as long as the one
that was on the athletic yesterday about
the eagles
the contributions of julian edelman to
the super bowl championships won
together in new england three for
edelman but six in all obviously for tom
brady with new england patriots so
today's draft
the
greatest
members of the patriots dynasty of the
past 20 years not named bill belichick
or tom brady chris you have a trivia
question for me that i am resisting the
temptation to look down and see what it
is all right don't look eyes forward
sergeant here we go edelman we know how
great he throws all those td passes
everything like that we remember the
danny amendola one in the 2014 post
season but who caught edelman's
lone
regular season td pass okay i'll give
you some hints because it's not easy it
was two years ago remember that
philadelphia game sunday afternoon in
philadelphia
right we ran the b-roll of the play
during earlier in the show i wasn't
watching the b-roll or he threw to a
receiver with the initials p and d
three
all
two
wrong dummy no it was a philip dorsett
no distraction
sorry demelitis is the dummy sorry
all right you get the first pick go
ahead
well
man okay i mean
i i think the first guy i'm going to go
i'm going to go with grunk i am i think
gronk is is the guy that i'm going to
put at the top of the list as far as
most valuable other patriot i mean
it's the greatest tight end in the
history of football
he was on a team that understood how to
utilize mismatches
better than any other team in the
history of football and i think with
that combination and the fact that the
guy was a beast in the pass game an
extra offensive tackle blocking in the
running game and of course became
brady's you know
little black you know comfortable
blanket and guy he went to in a big
moment no matter what it was
i think i gronk is the guy even though
it wasn't a real long long career it was
a real impactful career and uh you know
i think he made his mark up there for
sure
and look it it wasn't all offense
especially in the early years it was
defense and if we're going all the way
back to 2001 as we are i got to go
richard seymour yeah good for you more
what was the
you could argue even more important
aspect of those teams than tom brady he
was still kind of feeling his way along
and establishing who he was going to be
as a quarterback seymour heart and soul
of the team that won three in the first
uh four years of that dynasty yeah
that's a great one and that that really
that was one of the guys i was kind of
sitting there hemming and hauling about
as far as who i should take he's a hall
of famer richard seymour he is a hall of
famer he deserves to be in the hall of
fame he's unbelievable that's where
stats lie it's not about the stats with
that type of player i'd like to see you
know him get in eventually i think my
next one
you know i'm gonna go back to that arrow
too i am i'm gonna go to tai law i think
tai law is you know another guy i look
at and go well first off they don't win
the first super bowl without ty law
pick six to the house his ability to
cover isaac bruce and tory holt and be
you know on an island on certain plays
and do that stuff thai law was you know
big time for their football team let
alone he was the guy that they entrusted
to hey can you stop marvin harrison when
payton comes to town in the colts and do
that type of stuff you know he's a
phenomenal football player another guy
that i look at as a hall of fame talent
and really you talk about like there's
another defensive guy you could bring up
and go why didn't he win super bowl mvp
why i mean how big of a play it was the
greatest offense we ever saw in the
history of the planet and he had a pick
six and they held him to ten points
that's still crazy to me
and i remember that one afc championship
game where he picked off peyton manning
three times i mean yes right he
eventually got into canton and should
have and he was a key member of the
defense the first half of the patriots
dynasty
another key member of the first half of
the dynasty and a guy who was directly
responsible with the points generated by
his toe i got to go adam vinatieri i
mean they won those first three games i
know five three points each right and
they get into the first super bowl by
virtue of the kick that was made in the
snow globe in regulation and then the
kick that was made in the snow globe in
overtime and even though he left after
the 2005 season went to the colts and
was with the colts actually longer than
he was with the patriots he's always
going to be remembered as a member of
the patriots and his contributions to
those those far
narrower than we remember super bowl
victories they they need to be
acknowledged yeah no i agreed he was i
wrote him down too i mean i'm with you
you know i mean he's a part of the the
fabric of that that organization i mean
ice through his veins clutch
he kind of just he fit everything we
thought about them you know he just
always thought like oh here it is a big
moment okay belichick will call the
proper play brady will make the proper
throw and vina terry will make the
proper kick to send you off to your
locker room as a loser see you later
next contestant up to
go against the patriots i mean that's
really what it was like i mean it was
man i'm i'm stuck here there's some good
ones on the board i mean there really is
vince wilfork dante hightower brewski
rodney harrison stefan gilmore i mean
how gilmore is really the guy i want to
go to next because i didn't expect but i
got to go with julian edelman i'm going
with edelman yeah edelman to me just he
stands for everything that the patriots
are about yeah you know unknown guy
fighter finds his way onto the roster
johnny tryhard continues to get better
and better carves out a niche for the
football team you know and then becomes
really awesome at what he does for the
football team you know i mean he just to
me was part of the aura of the patriots
and kind of like what we just talked
about the second life of the patriots
was like okay well belichick's gonna
call the right play and brady's gonna
make the right throw either the gronk or
edelman and you're gonna lose and you're
gonna go to your locker room as a loser
next contestant up i mean that's just
how it felt edelman toughness special
teams punt returns trick plays whatever
he's a patriot for me all the way
and you know you you think of guys like
randy moss i know and wes welker i know
they they didn't want to super bowl with
either guy on the team they did not
that's i feel so bad
yeah i mean they had that 10-year gap
between super bowl wins edelman was
there for the final three neither moss
nor welker were there for the first
three so i thought about them but i'll
let him go i'm going to go back to the
first half of the dynasty again and i
know we're conflicted here because he's
our colleague but rodney harrison was
the guy that that really helped take
that defense to another level and i've
been around where you hear the stories
about how competitive
the defensive players were with each
other and how they held each other
accountable on top of rodney's skill the
thing he brought to the table was just
the intense desire to do everything
necessary to win
football games and
belichick has has lauded rodney harrison
as the greatest practice player that the
team's ever had and how do you get ready
for sunday you go out there and bust
your ass every opportunity you get i've
heard ronnie tell the stories about hey
that they used to be competitive about
hydrating who could drink their water
the fastest who would drink more water
everything that was a building block to
succeeding on sudden a rodney was all in
for every single little thing because he
knew that every single little thing led
to
being in position to win on sunday and
ultimately being in position to win
super bowls and he got two of them with
the patriots he arrived after the first
one key part of the defense in the next
two arguably could have been the super
bowl 39 mvp right against the eagles
yeah no and i mean listen was great on
the team that went undefeated and lost
to the giants i mean hey he's rodney was
amazing he he is he's all patriot dna
there's no doubt about that you know we
we see that with the way he acts and you
know added to that he was kind of the
you know lawyer malloy replacement and
that ended that conversation all
together but yeah when he got there
their defense went to another level and
i'm glad you picked him because i didn't
want to be beat up by him or have to see
you get beat up by him when we when we
get around him in the fall again hey
that's good i picked him you didn't
you don't get any of the credit you had
three shots you didn't pick him i picked
him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports